[Music]
rejected maybe you should just be one of
those indoor kids that reads maybe Molly
maids there will help clean up your face
that doesn't look very hard I want to
try do you want me to honestly tell you
how many times that took one you never
see rich people with trampolines it's
like an above-ground pool it's just not
an upscale piece of lawn furniture hey
at least they sprung for the safety net
what could go wrong well here's one
thing that could go wrong the kids could
start double-bouncing out of each other
for those of you who don't know what a
double bounce is it's the trampoline
equivalent of a speed ball for those of
you who don't know what a speedball is
its what killed John Belushi for those
of you who don't know who John Belushi
is he's Jim Belushi's brother for those
of you who don't know Jim is he's the
guy from according to Jim for those of
you who didn't watch according to Jim
congratulations oh wow is he up there
somebody just caught fire NBA Jam style
savor the moment Scotty Skiles because
it's about to turn sour that's a
technical foul get off the rim yes
suck it Vince Carter dangling by your
elbow doesn't seem like such a big deal
anymore it hurts to hear this is where
he and his torn ACL could learn a lesson
from Sasha just distribute the ball set
some screens and draw defenders out of
lane so real players can put on a show
and why is he crying like Nancy Kerrigan
you're right you don't get to dunk are
you trying to sexy up sports by having
girls play them I don't mean the WNBA I
mean girl girls there's lingerie
football foxy boxing and stripper golf
but ladies have nothing to masturbate to
while they watch sports and in my book
that's sexist that's why I created an
inner showbiz bottomless basketball
league
it's always tough plan against the cast
of Treme by now everyone knows instead
of winning basketball games the
honorable way Arizona State created the
curtain of distraction to screw with the
opposing team while they're taking foul
shots
[Applause]
that's innocent enough then they started
to get a little personal your test
results are in you have Hodgkins and
non-hodgkin's Hodgkins and non-hodgkin's
cancel each other out this next one I
thought was really scary you can't get
rid of the babadook don't mess with the
babadook that's just irresponsible this
one was a downright tearjerker is that a
mixed baby you give me that mixed baby I
won't happily raise him I'm not gonna
lie I found this next one a little
offensive finds Mike drei vier I declare
a dumb boy Jesus come on Adolf nobody
with the Jesus and then just when you
thought they couldn't be any more
distracting you heartless monsters go
and do this
[Applause]
brutal tactics ASU and you may actually
get off that NIT bubble women are always
trying to trap men by getting pregnant
which is crazy because ruining your body
permanently seems like a guaranteed way
to make sure I don't stick around but
this next girls prank takes it a little
too far
pregnant and even helped me out already
pregnant at a party
help me not funny a girl tried the
pregnant basketball prank on me ones oh
but I think I handled it pretty well hey
this is yours you got me pregnant are
you sure I'm sure
I'm sorry honey I have to do the right
thing
you see the doggy
I remember my frog all right one last
photo that couldn't be more proud of you
son
surely after that I'm sorry he rolled
into the street was hit by a car no
parent should ever have to bury their
basketball
you